yes yes
um so our first Speaker for the
afternoon session is Jacob steinhardt
um Jacob's a remarkable researcher who
kind of combines like
crazy creativity and um technical
know-how
um and he's gotten me to think very
differently about a lot of problems both
technically and uh I guess societally
um so I predict it will be a very
interesting talk thanks oh
[Applause]
thank you Sasha so I decided that I
wanted to talk about something uh new
kind of in the spirit of the Simon's
Workshop so uh these slides are actually
prepared totally from scratch no one has
seen them before except me on my laptop
so hopefully it'll be interesting
um so the kind of overall motivation
here is
um you know at least I really want to
understand what uh you know these ml
systems that we're deploying all over
the world are doing how they behave
what's going on under the hood but I
find this very challenging because
there's so many new ones uh you know
maybe like every month some some new
model is released and they get bigger
and more capable and more complex and so
how can our understanding of what these
models are doing keep up especially
given that we often get kind of new
capabilities or qualitative behaviors
just kind of emerging every time we
scale up and and so I think
um you know there's maybe more than one
answer to this but
um something that will be the focus of
this talk is the idea that well if we
can somehow use llms to understand llms
then maybe we're in better shape because
then every time a new better llm is
released well there's a new thing to
understand but we've also gotten better
at understanding things so uh you know
that's kind of the idea can we get this
virtuous cycle
um and uh and then you know hopefully as
models get better understanding will as
well um so this is going to be based on
work with actually a a lot of different
collaborators
um but uh three that I wanted to
highlight are my students uh Richie Eric
and Colin in particular
um a lot of the kind of llm as
statistician perspective in this talk uh
was developed by Richie so
um so what do I mean by L alums as
statisticians so what I want to argue is
that many forms of understanding that we
could care about essentially reduce to
some sort of statistical or data science
problem right so maybe uh we're given a
model we just see what it outputs on
some huge number of inputs right we
could easily do that by just taking all
of the data sets we have and seeing what
the model does and then maybe we want to
kind of identify patterns right are
there some things that the model is good
at some things it's bad at uh cases
where there's something surprising and
then you know you could try to formalize
that as some statistical hypothesis and
test it so that's kind of a statistical
problem maybe we want to understand the
training set and understand you know
what are the important sources of
variation
um uh you know if it turns out that
large fractions of the data set are in
some weird language called base64 maybe
we want to know about that and then you
could also have kind of more active
learning or active sampling problems
where we want to say generate new inputs
that elicit problematic behaviors so
that we can identify and fix it right so
I think of these all as on some level uh
kind of Statistics or data problems and
so if we can in some sort of General
sense get large language models to do
statistics then they can help us tackle
all of these problems and of course many
other useful problems as well
so uh to do that what would we need to
do so I'm going to kind of take a very
high level view of you know what is like
the pipeline of of doing statistics um
and I'd say it kind of has four steps
um the first is we look at some initial
data uh maybe we want to think of this
as training data but you know just some
sort of data that kind of helps us get
our bearings uh from this data we maybe
want to form some hypothesis you know
and maybe like the hypothesis that
models uh do worse on Long inputs than
short inputs right and then formalize
that quantitatively and then test this
on new data this data could just be you
know a held out set from the same
distribution we might care about kind of
you know generalization to new domains
or maybe if uh maybe we want to even
like actively collect data to really
stress test our hypothesis
um and so I'm going to go over a couple
case studies where we'll have problems
that kind of follow this structure and
we'll automate each step with llms
um the kind of key difference from maybe
traditional uh ways of looking at
statistics is going to be in this
hypothesis H so a key difference is you
know often H is like
um maybe expressed as some mathematical
function uh like uh you know patients
with this feature in a data set are more
likely to get this disease I can write
this as like expectation of some feature
function but here because we're working
with language models H is going to be a
natural language string and so this
third step which maybe is often almost
trivial it's just like taking the
average of your feature over the data
set now actually becomes kind of
non-trivial because we have to formalize
what it means for say a natural language
string to be true about a data set or
not
um so if that's kind of abstract don't
worry because we're going to go into
some case studies very soon in fact uh
right now okay so
um the first case study I want to talk
about is finding failures in a model
called clip so for those who aren't
familiar with it clip is an encoder
model so it takes in inputs and kind of
embeds them as as some feature vector
and it's kind of used as the backbone of
many later models right so it's often
useful to have good embeddings so many
models kind of use these embeddings and
then do something with them and the
thing that is kind of special about clip
is that it embeds both images in Tech
and text into a kind of shared space so
it was one of the most early multimodal
models uh that kind of did this
effectively
and as sort of shown here lots of models
use it so mid-journey uses it as its
kind of first embedding step dilated
stable diffusion does um and lots of
like 3D and video models do as well
um and you can kind of get pretty
amazing results using these embeddings
often they're used to kind of do text to
image Generations so you have some text
description of what you want and then
these models kind of try to generate an
image that you know matches this
description in some way so you can see
here if you these are maybe a little bit
small but this doesn't Empty Glass and
then you get this glass a family of five
members and then you get this a man
descending a mountain you get this so
these are all amazing except for the
problem that they're also all completely
wrong right this is a full glass this is
a family of six members this is someone
us sending a mountain that says there's
no star in the night sky and it shows uh
the Milky Way and so you get these
amazing images but you often get these
uh you know kind of like very
semantically obvious failures
um so uh the kind of plot twist here
aside from the fact that uh here's a
bunch of failures that we can find is
actually that we didn't find these
failures uh and llm found these failures
so these were all automatically
generated by actually not a single llm
but a kind of pipeline of several llms
working together on kind of
complementary uh tasks that played to
their individual strengths so we'll talk
about you know how could we actually
build a system that you know just
givenclip could kind of automatically
generate all of these failures at a
large scale
uh so are there any questions so far
before I go into the details of this
ah yes one question why do you say Dolly
uh new Bing what what does that mean in
this context uh there's
I think different versions of Dolly and
uh one of them I'm not totally sure of
the details here but I believe that um
you know Dolly was developed by open AI
but then Microsoft serves some version
of Dolly as part of their being product
and so this is uh that uh which we use
because we can actually query it uh kind
of uh you know publicly ah yes
are there any new type
are there any new type of errors that
pop-up from this process for example
like the counting error or the direction
error those are already kind of known
right so are there any new hypothesized
formed in this process yeah so that's a
good question so I'll get to kind of
numbers later
um we
generated 14 categories of Errors we
looked for papers that kind of described
these errors I think there were a
handful that had already been described
in the literature the others were not in
the literature I would probably guess
that you know someone whose day job was
to like play around with these models
would be familiar with these errors but
the nice thing is you like even without
spending lots and lots of time uh you
can do this in fact like uh you know
it's I think there were cases where you
know like reviewers asked us to like add
a new system to this pipeline in like a
half hour we just got like all of the
new errors that that system had so
um so I think right now uh that's the
advantage is that it's much quicker I
think as models become better I'm hoping
that we'll also get things that even
like an expert who spent lots and lots
of time might not necessarily find
uh yeah great question any other
questions
okay so how do we do this
um so first maybe let me uh give a kind
of
overview of the key ideas here
um right so again remember clip is this
feature encoder that is encoding both
text and images so like kind of main key
idea in terms of like where we get off
the ground is there's going to be a sort
of notion of what I'll call a hash
Collision in the encoder and uh we'll
come up with a sort of automated way of
identifying lots of hash collisions in
the encoder so this is going to give us
a lot of kind of like individual
examples where if you you know if you
have a collision you don't know which of
those two is wrong but you know at least
one of them has to be wrong
um uh then kind of given those failures
we're going to use llms to kind of
categorize them into coherent patterns
and test that those patterns are
actually correct by generating new
examples uh from those patterns and
making sure that they actually you know
in fact induce failures consistently
both in the encoder and on Downstream
tasks and even kind of also generalizing
to uh to new domains that are kind of
different from uh what we found these
patterns on so that's kind of a high
level let me kind of Step through these
all one by one right so again remember
we had this statistical pipeline of you
know get some data generate a hypothesis
formalize the hypothesis test it on new
data so let's just go through these one
by one so first let's just talk about
you know where are we getting this
initial data um what is this kind of
hash Collision idea so to talk about
this I need to give you a little bit
more background on uh clip so as I said
before clip embeds either image you know
an image I or text t uh but what is it
actually designed to do or what was it
sort of trained on so it's actually
trained on a bunch of pairs of images
and their captions and in general the
idea is that uh if there's text that
describes an image then that text in
that image should have a similar
embeddings ideally more similar
embeddings to each other than to
anything else so the training process
was basically you got a bunch of images
you got a bunch of captions and then you
want to make sure that under this
embedding you know the cosine similarity
between an image and its caption is
higher than between that you know image
and any other caption so you kind of
want if we form this Matrix of dot
products you want the diagonal to be
really big and everything else to be
really small
um and so the kind of Point here is that
if T is a description of I they should
have similar embeddings
um
now how can I use this to find problems
well
if T and T Prime describe different
images but have the same embedding or
have very similar embeddings then at
least one of them has to be wrong
um in some sense right because uh they
sh you know like uh whatever images he's
corresponded to they kind of can't both
be uh they can't both be right oh yes
that's a rejection between images and
text and we know that uh you know you
know picture is worth a thousand words
um
right so I'm the the examples I have in
mind would be something like an empty
cup and a full cup and if those like if
those sentences actually had the same
embedding but those are that's that's a
very small subset of all the like
there's a lot of synonyms and right to
the visual symbols
that's right so you have to worry about
visual synonyms
um so we need uh we need some way of
measuring kind of semantic difference
that hopefully implies that things are
actually visually different um so I'll
get to that on the next slide
um other questions though
all right so one thing here also is the
nice thing is that I can do this only
looking at text right I mean I have to
use the clip encoder but I'm only
encoding text and why do I want to only
look at text well basically because
language models work really well and
image models don't
um I'm sorry
um uh but you know according to all the
OSHA image models will work really well
soon even better but right now right now
we want to stick with language
so uh so what do we do uh we're gonna
collect some initial Corpus of text
inputs um and we want these inputs to be
inputs that have some visual
significance
um so we'll often take them uh from some
say captioning data set or other kind of
uh data set uh that has visual
descriptions and then we're going to
embed them all under clip and we're also
going to embed them under another model
called distill Roberta which is a very
uh good text model especially for
embeddings so it's a text only model
um and it's also uh has a higher
dimensional embedding space than clip
and so for both of these reasons it's
kind of you know has a better
understanding of text than clip does
because it gets to only focus on text
and it has more parameters and so the
basic idea is uh you know so we have all
these uh clip embeddings and if there's
two inputs that are very close in clip
space but actually have low Roberta
similarity right so that means they're
kind of different like Roberto thinks
that they're semantically different
sentences but Clips says they're the
same then we're going to say okay that's
a hash Collision uh probably something
is wrong there now we I agree with you
that we also want to check that these
really are semantically different in a
way that matters visually
um empirically it turns out that that's
the case about 90 of the time so this is
kind of good enough and this is
something we kind of verified with human
uh human subject studies
um Jacob how do you find this because
aren't the clip vectors like 2048
dimensional or something uh
uh yeah so we're just uh
we're just taking uh the cosine
similarity so this is like this is an N
squared L and N squared algorithm yeah
but okay but I mean if we imagine that
you were just looking for collisions in
this 2048 dimensional space we would say
a priori that could take astronomical
time and you're saying like like in
practice it takes
these text inputs that makes the
collisions likelier so so yeah a couple
of things I guess first we don't need
exact collisions
um if the cosine similarity is large
enough I guess empirically if it's
larger than 0.88 it turns out that uh
it's pretty likely to create a problem
um so you don't need them to be exactly
the same that kind of helps you somewhat
and and yeah so uh somehow this but I
mean two unit vectors having an inner
product of 0.88 in the 2048 dimensional
space that we we might as well call that
a collision right at that point but he's
he's a he's assuming N squared time for
u n would be exponential right the
Collision so okay right so Scott's
claiming we would need an exponentially
large data set but this is not yeah
uh yeah yeah but okay so but it it
happens that so so basically the reason
why there are collisions is not has
nothing to do with like the pigeonhole
principle with the space right it's just
that that you know the the the the way
that it's something special about this
mapping that causes there to be
collisions even though yes
there could have been not no collisions
yeah that's right okay
couldn't you do it much faster by using
the same kind of hnsw in the season all
of the embeddings
yeah you could do that you could do this
much faster than N squared it just
turned out that this is not the uh
bottleneck like the bottleneck is
running the forward passes of uh all the
models and uh kind of looping over a
bunch of uh pairs of you know a
thousand-dimensional vectors is pretty
pretty cheap compared to running an llm
choose yeah so we tried two different
corpora one is Coco and um the other is
uh what's the other one uh snli yeah
um these are both kind of Text data sets
that have visual significance
um and yeah I mean basically the point
is that there's enough yeah there's
enough structure in text that you
actually do get collisions
uh I don't care about the N squared okay
okay got it got it
um okay so this is the first step right
this is going to give us a bunch of
pairs where we kind of know that like
one of the two things in the pair is
wrong
um and so now we want to do something
with that
so uh this is kind of the next stage is
we want to generate some hypotheses
based on these pairs right so this is
where we're going to use the fact that
we're we have text and not images right
so the individual failures are text
inputs so you can feed them to gpt4 and
so uh you know here's the magical prompt
uh it says I'll provide a series of data
for you to remember uh subsequently
It'll ask you some questions to test
your performance here's some pairs of
problems to memorize and then you give
it
um all of well you give it as many of
these failures as you can fit in the
context window and then you tell it hey
I'm trying to find failures with an
embedding model uh these are pairs that
set of sentences that are encoded very
similarly using the specific examples
are there any general types of failures
you notice the embedding is making and
then uh you know you kind of give it
some more more context and you'd say
okay what does it generate right so
you're basically saying here's some data
please look at it please tell me some
patterns
um and so then it uh you know it does uh
a pretty good job of coming up with
things it says okay there's negation
temporal differences quantifiers
um and the nice thing is actually it
doesn't just say negation but it gives
um a bunch of elaborations so it says
embedding models may not correctly
capture the negative context in a
sentence that into similarities between
sentences with and without negation
um uh this can result in incorrect
visual representations as the presence
or absence of an action is significant
image or video generation
um and uh it kind of keeps going
um and you get uh I guess in this case
you get kind of 14 uh distinct failures
in total on this list
um and the other thing is empirically
gv4 just kind of always uses this
consistent list format so you can
automatically just parse out the
individual hypotheses oh yeah Lisa
it's like asking GPT without these like
inputs like what are common failure
cases of image embedding models or
something yes so that's uh that's a
baseline uh that I will show results on
later and uh yeah it works a lot less
well
um okay so
uh so this kind of gives us hypotheses
uh right so this was step two uh but now
we're running into this problem of okay
usually in statistics a hypothesis is
like actually some mathematical function
but here these are just sentences uh you
know so now we need to formalize this
hypothesis right so we have this list of
hypotheses H1 through h k that are all
natural language descriptions so how can
we test if one of these hypotheses is
actually uh any good
um so I think this is a pretty
interesting conceptual question to think
about so maybe I'll pose it to the
audience uh if anyone has ideas for how
we could formalize this
all right Chris could ask
about payers as to whether they match
this hypothesis
are wrong
okay
if you have access good yes uh so that
is uh yeah do you uh I mean if we think
about research hypothesis as there are a
few Dimensions that you can use to
categorize whether Samsung is a
hypothesis so for example it should be
testable right there should be a clear
scope there are a few Dimensions I think
that you can come up with based on
access
uh right so you can kind of ask experts
or gpt4 if it had those uh properties
um so it turns out we're going to do
something uh pretty similar to what
Chris said uh although we're going to
look at generation rather than
classification so we're going to say h
is a good hypothesis if when you uh hand
that description to
um some intelligent agent in this case
not humans because humans are expensive
but gpt4 uh they do a better job of
generating new failures than they would
otherwise
um so this is uh this is the uh way
we're going to quantify this so we'll
say h is a good hypothesis if it can be
used to generate uh new failures better
than some just Baseline method of
generating failures
and this is this is where we're going to
get to your question Lisa so we can
either hand GPT for these hypotheses or
we could just ask you before to like
brainstorm without any data ways in
which Vision models might be bad
um and kind of test those against each
other and see which one does better
um okay right so we're going to test
this by prompting an LM with each of the
context and so again what is the magical
prompt
um the magical prompt is to say write
down uh 41 pairs of prompts that an
embedding model with the following
failure mode might encode similarly even
though they would correspond to
different images if used as captions uh
use the following format so you give it
kind of a format so that we can extract
things programmatically
um and then we say some other stuff to
motivate it saying that it will be
evaluated based on how well it performs
um and then you give the failure mode
and uh as kind of the description that
we extracted before uh y41
um that's the link basically the length
of the output context window that uh can
be fit so if you want more than 41 you
just have to ask it a couple times
uh so this is uh this is what we did
ah yeah Nicholas
how much does this be creative and
cautious and these kinds of things like
actually help or is this just like black
magic that you sort of
sprinkle on top
we didn't do careful ablations on the
prompt
um
I think yeah uh we added a bunch of
stuff until it worked and uh I don't
think we tried removing things to see
what was actually necessary so it seems
totally like I would guess that if you
tried to like distill this to its Bare
Essentials you could get something
simpler uh but we didn't try to do that
uh but yeah great question
okay
um so right so then we want to quantify
by measuring the success rate right so
we get all these pairs of prompts that
are supposedly supposed to
uh be new failures so we can do this in
two ways right we can look at uh the
fraction of things generated that our
hash collisions in the same sense as
before
uh so that's kind of an easy thing to do
uh at some point we want to make sure
that the system's like actually doing
something and that the something doesn't
involve trusting that llms are good at
uh their job so uh we also do a human
evaluation where we look at Downstream
systems that rely on clip and ask humans
if uh if there's a failure to make sure
that you know these actually are
failures and not just happen to have
high cosine similarity uh so those are
the two things we do
um so let's kind of go over the results
so uh first just kind of looking at hash
collisions
um
but testing on these new new inputs that
were generated
um so we say an input has a success if
you know these similarities are above
some threshold
um and what is this table saying so
these rows are kind of the different uh
failures generated by the system and
actually we considered uh six different
systems so there's uh you can ask
different models to look at the data and
propose hypotheses so these are
different kind of proposer models gpt4
Claude or GPD 3.5 and then you can also
vary the data set that you used uh to
actually uh get these failures out so
these are the two data sets that people
asked about before Coco and snli so I
guess a couple interesting things uh one
is that oh and a check mark means that
the model uh generated the failure at
all in its list and then the color is
kind of the success rate of generating
new uh new inputs conditional on that uh
failure description so a couple
interesting things first of all the data
set seems to actually matter right so
kind of uh
for both gpd4 and Claude uh
uh action uh uh well okay maybe let's
pick a more intuitive one uh okay so for
both gpd4 and Claude uh and GV 3.5
snli elicits uh granularity as a failure
whereas uh Coco never does and sometimes
it's kind of not quite so systematic but
in general it sort of seems like these
data sets actually do kind of uh like
elicit different failures so there is at
least some dependence on the data which
is somewhat reassuring
um the other thing is maybe as expected
gpd4 and Claude in general find many
more failures than g3.5 does so these
better models actually generate more
distinct hypotheses
and then a final thing that is
interesting is actually even for the
same failure uh bigger models
often are
um giving you higher success rates so
you can see this in a couple places like
for granularity uh the description of
the granularity failure that g54
generated was apparently better in terms
of if you then hand that back to GPT for
it more successfully generates uh novel
failure instances compared to uh the
kind of description that GPD 3.5 gave
um in all of these cases we're fixed in
gpd4 as kind of the thing that's
generating new failures so there's no
effect from that
um uh so this is this kind of difference
is just coming from the actual like text
description output by them all
um okay so are there any questions about
this data
about when gpk4 does better than GPT 3.5
is it because it better understood the
destruction
versus
um maybe GPT 3.5 also understood the
description but somehow an example is
organized
I'm just curious like what what sort of
qualitative differences are there
between
yeah so
I haven't thought about this a ton I
think uh my two main hypotheses here
would be
um I believe gpd4 has a larger context
window so it can see more examples which
might be useful
um but I think probably the more
important thing is actually just that
um like the task of proposing uh
hypotheses from a data set is actually a
pretty uh like challenging task and so
uh even kind of like Frontier models are
own like are not that good at it so then
once you drop down from gbd4 to GB 3.5
you're kind of losing
um probably just like losing too much
capability uh for it to be super
consistent that would be my hypothesis I
don't know if yeah Richie yeah so like
in practice we found uh GPS 3.5 doesn't
really commission all the data very well
while gb4 actually does come to channel
on the beta and then describe the same
thing
yes
samples of the model generated actually
fall into those categories
so I don't think we did a systematic
evaluation of whether all of the
examples fall into those categories
um
I yeah I can give some uh I can give
Sounders on the next slide that sort of
that get at least like implicitly at
that
um it looked like maybe someone else had
a question
okay so so maybe let's let's go to the
uh human evaluation which will at least
partially answer your question so uh so
we wanted to not just stick with saying
that you know you actually get these
hash collisions uh but show that these
actually lead to images that humans say
are wrong
um so okay darn the text here is a
little bit small but
um this is kind of the human annotator
interface uh that we uh gave so
um we had uh prompt one uh a city
skyline with a bridge it's promptuous in
East Skyline without a bridge right so
this is this kind of collision pair this
is an image that was Ren or like was uh
come come from Kim from one of these two
prompts chosen at random and so the
annotator has to say either that this
corresponds to prompt one
uh it corresponds to prompt two
it corresponds to neither of them
um or these prompts are described
visually identical situations so this
kind of gets at uh your earlier question
aliosha on whether these are actually
semantically different
um and so we're kind of measuring you
know what counts as a Successful Failure
either if the annotator says uh that
it's uh wrong or if they say it's prompt
two but it was actually generated by
prompt one or vice versa
um and so then you can look at the kind
of uh you know rate app which uh
mistakes are made uh conditional on
different levels of clip similarity in
the two prompts right so this is kind of
testing that high similarity actually
leads to failures and you can kind of
see there's this like inflection point
at like uh Point Day date
um so this is uh this is kind of one
verifying that actually we do get pretty
high rates of failure and two that this
magical threshold I told you about
earlier is actually kind of reasonable
threshold
um and then finally to get at this
question of whether these descriptions
are actually doing anything so I guess
this doesn't test whether the failures
correspond to the descriptions but it
tests that the descriptions are actually
needed to get high failure rates if you
have a baseline system where you just
ask it to like brainstorm possible
failures images might have and then
condition on those uh you only get about
uh 20 failure rate whereas you get an 80
failure rate if you use this data
conditioned system
so these are the
um uh uh these are the human evaluated
rather than model evaluated
um so are there questions about this
this is a talk where High failure rate
is better yes yeah you want High failure
because we're trying to find failures so
that we can fix them
uh okay and then I guess a final cool
thing is uh you know a kind of really
big bonus of having this come from
language models is language models are
kind of automatically steerable right so
I have this way of generating failures
but I can then just ask the model to
give me failures that are relevant to
some new domain
um and uh so in this case we kind of
asked it to generate failures that are
relevant to self-driving the data sets
are still Coco and snli so we didn't
give it data that would specialize to
self-driving but it can still kind of
generate these failures in the in this
novel domain and still have a good
success rate and so these are just kind
of examples uh stable diffusion you have
the cars on the right side of the lane
but it's on the left side this is not a
green light gives you a green light a
yield sign gives you something that is
at least not shaped like a yield sign
probably a stop sign and then a car
stops for a red light this is actually a
texture video model
um and uh the light is green so oh yes
data from Coco and SNL are you passing
engineering or like are you testing an
image no no so you're passing in the
text from so this is for the like very
first stage where you're giving it a
bunch of just text inputs and like
embedding them to check for hash
collisions so those hash collisions were
from embedding text sentences from Coco
and snli so there's no images there's
actually no images anywhere here except
in the output of the systems
I'm kind of curious about uh the
hypothesis part of this and whether
that's kind of necessary so um
we had a paper a couple years ago and
just tried to finding these collisions
and I kind of wonder if you could just
give it a sentence and like search for a
collision and just cut out the language
model what is it adding in in the
process
um
well finding the
so I think one thing is this durability
I think would be challenging in some
cases if you were doing that because you
would need a large data set of text in
whatever new domain you were looking at
right like we don't need a bunch of
sentences about self-driving cars to do
this but if you were looking for
collisions manually then you would have
to do that
I see
yes um
uh okay so to summarize this right we
had these four stages of you know first
we want to get initial data which we did
by scraping hash collisions for this
text data set
um this uh kind of invoked these two
models uh clip and distill Roberta then
we generate hypotheses by prompting gpt4
uh then we kind of formalize these
hypotheses by looking at the success
rate of generating new failures right so
we use gpd4 to generate the failures and
clip to evaluate them
um and then we can also do this active
steering again prompting gpd4 so I think
one thing I want to highlight here right
is that uh you know often we think about
just having this one language model that
we just come up with you know our super
clever prompt uh that solves everything
and maybe do chain of thoughts and uh
this sort of thing but I think you can
actually get a lot further if you're
willing to kind of uh use this kind of
um you know ecosystem of models together
in
uh in creative ways and I think
statistics is a particularly kind of
good use case for this because there are
these different stages of the pipeline
that require kind of different skills
and statistics also have some nice
properties right like many parts of it
are kind of automatically measurable and
uh verifiable and so you get a lot of
the same strengths as
um as Adam was talking about yesterday
with computer uh programming where you
know you can we haven't done much of
this but like you can you know maybe do
this self training and maybe we could
get models that were really really
really good at statistics like
superhuman statistics uh because there's
so much automatically generatable data
okay
um so that was the first case study
um let me go over the second one uh
we'll go a bit more quickly now that
we've kind of built up a lot of these uh
conceptual ideas so here I'm actually
going to talk about a kind of meta task
uh that is then going to be useful for
lots of individual ways in which we
would want to understand language models
um so this meta task is classifying with
natural language predicates so the task
here is we're going to be given two Text
data sets D1 and D2 We want to find out
what's different between them and this
difference again should be some natural
language string H and so you can kind of
think about this as isomorphic to Binary
classification right we're kind of
trying to classify between D1 and D2 but
where the function is described in
natural language
um so let me just give you an example of
what this task might look like right so
maybe these are my two data sets D1 and
D2 We want to come up with a natural
language uh description of how they're
different so can anyone figure this one
out
in English okay yes so uh the left is
French and the right is English so our H
would be D1 contains more French
sentences compared to D2
okay so here's a harder example
maybe partly hard due to text size
um
but I claim that even if you looked at
this for a while
it would be hard to tell what the
difference was
and in fact the difference is that
sentences in D1 contain at least two
female characters in them whereas
sentences in D2 do not this is actually
pretty challenging because
um there's things like she carried a
total of eight Torpedoes where she
refers to a ship
which is not in fact a female character
and you also have to know that Professor
mikion is female
um and so uh so there's kind of a lot of
World Knowledge and kind of non-trivial
stuff in solving a problem like
uh so I guess that's the kind of meta
task why should we care about this so
first I'll give you three use cases that
would help us better understand uh llms
uh so right we could want to understand
uh distribution shift so especially you
know if a model is doing poorly out of
distribution maybe we want to diagnose
what's different and so we might find
out that the test distribution involves
more formal writing than the training
distribution and that might help us
diagnose failures or tell us what we
should fine tune on the positive class
contains more URLs than the negative
class uh If This Were a Spam
classification data set this would tell
us that there was this potential
spurious cue that maybe the model just
looks at the presence or absence of URLs
and we should make sure that that's not
just what it's doing
um we could do error analysis right I
could give you two models and I could
look at the difference between inputs
where one of them versus the other one
makes mistakes
um and then you know if we could also go
beyond just trying to understand llms
you know you could start trying to do uh
you know for like say like social
science right uh I look at a bunch of
tweets from one year versus another year
and uh it turns out and say okay public
opinion from this year is more
optimistic about the pandemic than last
year right uh we can kind of uh generate
at least uh descriptive hypotheses like
this of course you would then want to
carefully do all of the causal inference
and and other stuff to validate these
but this at least can generate uh
hypotheses for you
um okay so how will we do this well ISD
so uh if you go back to the examples you
have
um it feels like it's a hypothesized
space
huge right so there seems to be a recall
Precision issue here and it seems your
ground truth only has some of them
um like for them it's a very easy
example my hypothesis could it be
there's no relation between those two
sentences or I mean you have like it has
more French versus the second sentence
the space seems huge
to the final ones we want so we're not
going to have a ground truth in most
cases there are a couple cases where we
did create a ground truth
um to so that we could kind of test in
the traditional setting with uh with
kind of gold labels
um but we're going to kind of take a
similar perspective to how you would
evaluate any other classifier right so
we're going to come up with a way to
quantify these in terms of some
classification error rate and then we'll
say that one hypothesis is better than
another if it has a lower error rate in
distinguishing D1 and D2 and so rather
than having a fixed ground truth we can
just talk about which systems are better
or worse and maybe we could also say
compare to humans so you get some like
overall benchmark
the sum of the hypothesis might be very
true and others may be more usable right
right okay right so
um
there's right so you might also want to
evaluate if there's some like goal you
might want to evaluate like relevance to
the goal and some notion of novelty
um these become start to become
subjective so we have done some of this
where we get human ratings of of novelty
and relevance
um uh
reviewers didn't like it actually
because uh it's too hard to define
novelty but uh but anyways like you can
do this and uh like I think uh
but I do agree it's kind of a tricky
problem uh yes so just building on these
questions uh is are you
are you in are you constraining some of
some complexity of the hypothesis are
you looking for short hypotheses
um so we'll implicitly have Rel will
implicitly have short hypotheses here
although that kind of just comes from
the fact that these are going to be
generated by an llm and llms will only
output things that are so long
okay uh but yeah we like for usability
reasons you would want this to be uh
kind of short and interpretable
okay
um cool so yeah how are you going to do
this uh we're basically just going to
use llms uh uh somewhat similarly to
before right so I won't give you the
full magical prompt uh that Rachel came
up with but just kind of schematically
uh we kind of give it a bunch of
examples from uh the first distribution
and label them as a a bunch from the
second label them as B and then uh we
say you know compared to Group B each
sentence from group a and then we ask it
to complete it this was done at a point
where we were using gpd3
um so we needed it to be in this
completion format once you have
instruction tuned models there's uh
maybe uh nicer prompts you can have uh
but this is kind of the basic idea and
then you
you sample this a bunch of times uh with
different you know sub samples of the
data right so keep in mind that we can
only fit maybe like 30 or so examples
into the context window so we have a
data set with thousands of examples is
like a very tiny fraction so we kind of
keep sub sampling to generate different
hypotheses
um and then uh you know you'll get
things like is more positive contains
the word chapter is longer
um some of them actually kind of have uh
yeah some of them end up being kind of
trivial so you might want ways of
filtering them out but you kind of get
this set of candidate hypotheses
um so this is kind of uh telling us how
we do the first two steps of the
statistics pipeline right we look at
this initial data uh we prompt GPT uh n
for some n with examples from uh D1 and
D2 and then we ask how they're different
in this forms a hypothesis but now we
need to somehow formalize age
quantitatively and test it on new data
um so I guess again maybe I'll pose the
question uh you know how how can we
formalize
this age quantitatively
how can we sort of say quantitatively
how good is it
oh
yeah
sorry what do you say for sure
okay good right so we can say
uh
you know a good hypothesis is something
that helps tell D1 and D2 apart so will
uh you know take a sample from D1 a
sample from D2 mix them up randomly so
you don't know which is which
uh tell either a human or an llm uh the
hypothesis and ask them to say which is
which
um so uh you know as an example say h is
involves more formal writing we can
interpret this as basically a two
argument predicate right so if I have
sentences X1 and X2 h of X1 X2 is some
binary predicate that is the truth value
of you know the utterance X1 involves
more formal write-in than X2 and so this
should be true or false and so then we
just ask
um
a human or language model if it's true
or false and so then we'll say h is a
correct hypothesis about D1 versus D2 if
an expectation over samples X1 from D1
and X2 from D2 uh this is much less than
0.5 right so 0.5 would be chance if this
is sort of the like some measure of the
classification error if it's much less
than 0.5 then we've uh We've figured out
something non-trivial about uh D1 and D2
um and so yeah how to implement this uh
uh I guess uh
uh you could ask humans uh or you could
just query an llm
and so what does this look like right so
um just to illustrate this if H is
sampled from D1 are more positive than
those from D2 uh we you know we give in
this case uh Charlie Snell who was an
undergrad at Berkeley at the time and is
now a PhD student at Berkeley
um this paper proposes an impractical
task or the approach of this paper is
too trivial
um and ask him which of these it's true
about and then he says something and
then uh you know maybe Charlie's time is
pretty valuable so you can hire crowd
workers to do this instead
um uh but the problem is you know even
even if we just wanted to average over
say like 100 uh samples from this
distribution to get some notion of
accuracy uh uh this would cost ten
dollars per text description and this is
uh uh very expensive
um uh you don't want to do this and so
uh the nice thing is llms kind of reduce
the cost of this pipeline by about a
factor of a thousand uh you can do this
hundred samples for only uh seven cents
with GPD 3.5 turbo
um and so then this gives you a kind of
automatic quantifiable measure of uh how
successful this hypothesis is and the
nice thing is also that it's somewhat
more reproducible than humans like you
don't have to worry about getting back
the same human labelers again because uh
you know the model well the model's not
actually fixed open AI keeps updating it
that's kind of annoying
um but if they were to serve a stable
version of the model then uh this would
be reproducible
okay
um right so now now we've kind of uh
uh got in this whole pipeline right so
the overall system is we have this
proposer
um which uh at the time we initially
wrote this paper was a fine-tuned gpt3
that generates these candidate
hypotheses and then we have a verifier
that kind of you know does this check on
each of the hypotheses uh at the time it
was fine-tuned unified QA uh now you can
kind of replace with newer models
um and then you kind of you know re-rank
the hypotheses based on their actual uh
success rate of this classification task
and you know why is this decomposition
useful well from an engineering
perspective and I think this is actually
very important the proposer only sees 30
examples because that's the length of
its context window so it's in that sense
fairly limited even though it's this
very smart uh like GPT three or four
system whereas the verifier can see
thousands of examples and so you can get
much better tests of statistical
significance
um uh how am I doing on time
um you've about five minutes left yeah
okay cool
um so maybe I'll just say you know you
can use this for a bunch of things so
for describing distribution shifts
um there's these two data sets mli and
snli where snli is often used as like an
OD version of mnli
um here's four samples two of which are
from
snli and two of which are from mnli and
maybe it's not immediately obvious
uh
uh what distinguishes them but if I say
that snli describes a picture then uh
it's very clear that the green ones are
snli because it says the church choir
sings to the masses and old man with the
packages poses in front of an
advertisement and the uh other two are
not about pictures so you kind of
immediately see what the distribution
shift is here
um uh there's two paraphrase data sets
uh Twitter pptv and qqp which stands for
core question pairs it says Twitter
talks about a news story and quora
contains a question
um these are just kind of Sanity checks
like these would be kind of totally
obvious to anyone who was familiar with
these data sets but you can do more
interesting things so
um this was one that I think to our
knowledge was novel at the time we
discovered it detecting Superior cues in
a data set so we handed it this data set
called subj which is a data set for
subjectivity analysis and it said the
objective class was a plot summary have
a film and the subjective class is a
quote from a film review which seems
like it should be wrong for a data set
that's about subjectivity analysis
um but if you actually go back and read
the paper it says uh together subjective
sentences we collected 5000 movie review
Snippets from Rotten Tomatoes to obtain
mostly objective data we took five
thousand sentences from plot summaries
available from IMDb so actually if you
did well on this data set you were
basically learning this rather than uh
stuff about subjectivity
um
there's like other shortcuts we found
somewhere new some were old but you can
sort of find all these various cues you
can use this for error analysis
um and so on so maybe just to summarize
right we have these four steps of this
pipeline
um initial data was just the two text
distributions generate the hypothesis by
prompting gpd3
formalize the hypothesis by measuring
the success rate and then you kind of
test on new held out samples
um
uh the final thing I'll just leave up is
uh uh we have ongoing work that is kind
of taking this far beyond classification
to just sort of like generally using
natural language predicates as features
in statistical models
um so this example here is trying to
describe uh temporal drift in uh news
headlines from the Australian
Broadcasting Company and it kind of
identifies uh these five uh features
that kind of vary and you could think of
as maybe the top five principal
components explain the variation in this
data set although the percent of
variance explained is actually still
pretty low here so I think you should
think of this as just like uh a uh
like uh initial results
um so maybe I'll end there and take
questions
[Applause]
so for the purposer can be just like do
prompt optimization like over time you
keep selecting like an example and then
see where it fails and then show it
again and then after avoid you have like
these good hypothesis and that you can
somehow guarantee that is correct in a
set of checking things
um so you could so is the idea like
basically like fine-tuned the proposer
to get better and better uh yeah fine
tune the prompt you do that prompt
optimization oh prompt optimization
um so
I think
so my general sense is if you just use
the proposer I mean we didn't try to do
like the full prompt optimization but we
do do ablations of like just using the
proposer and that generally does a lot
worse
um I think that there's a couple issues
one is just that the proposer gets much
less data than the verifier so you know
even like if you do prompt optimization
I I'm sorry oh no what's your I thought
that your proposal like get like a few
number of data that's why you should do
the checking yeah and then I was just
saying that can you make the proposer
more strong but just to prompt oh I see
I can't see everything and then you can
guarantee that this hypothesis is
correct
um
yeah so that's that's an interesting
idea so you're basically saying okay
like do prompt optimization to find a
prompt that gets this
um I feel like we discussed this what
was your claim is that you don't get
semantically
suppose that you do gradients you just
gradient descent to find the prompts
then you are you very easily get like
unreadable prompts that is not natural
language stream because what you
typically find with adversary examples
they are relatively pathological
yeah so I think the issue is at least
right now if you do this it's hard to
get kind of like natural language out
right now you asked gpt4 to give you
Canadians but
thank you for this amazing talk
um the quick question maybe this is not
so you're asking uh you're asking for
hypotheses that separate the two data
set uh and when you were testing them
they were like okay let me pick two
examples and say one is more positive
than the other but uh could you tweak
this to possibly look for hypotheses
that
certainly answer yes in one case and no
in the other case that you don't have to
look at two comparative examples like
okay this one talks of a female
character the other one talks for male
character
so what uh what would be just so I can
understand like what would be an example
prompt you might so as an example uh the
the second data the second example you
showed was that this statement talks of
two female characters that's a statement
you can answer in yes or no without
looking at two different samples from
the two data yeah yeah yeah right so so
could you tweak this to possibly just
look for hypotheses that could be
answered on a single data point rather
than a comparison between data points
from different data sets yeah so we
actually I think worked with both
versions of the system one that is kind
of unary predicates and one that's
binary predicates
um I think in practice a lot of the
interesting things you want out are kind
of binary predicates so you can get like
you can get somewhere with this unary
thing but you're kind of losing
something if you don't consider
comforters
okay let's thank the speaker
[Music]
[Applause]